welcome to today's event on the politics
of international media rankings it's a
great pleasure to welcome you this is
part of our Harriman Institute series on
human rights in the post-communist
sphere actors strategies and outcomes
co-hosted and co-directed by Jack
Schneider in Columbia Department
political science and myself this is one
branch of the project seeks to identify
some of the politics surrounding the
proliferation of rankings and indices
and so we had an event on the politics
of corruption rankings in October we
will have another event next week on the
politics of illicit indicators in the
contestant politics of numbers that will
feature peter andreas of Brown
University Sally Mary of nyu in our own
Lara nettle field amongst others so this
is an ongoing theme over the next year
or so and we're delighted to have you be
part of it now today's panel is
remarkably distinguished and it combines
academics practitioners but both
academics and practitioners seem to do
both and so that's that's a really nice
aspect of this so let me introduce them
briefly in the order that they'll be
speaking Lee Becker is director of the
james m cox jr center for international
mass communication training and research
and professor in the department of
journalism Grady College of Journalism
and mass communication University of
Georgia professor Becker has written
extensively on audience uses of the mass
media and the effects of media messages
on the audience members and on society
he is the author of two books using mass
communication theory with Maxwell
McCombs and the training and hiring of
journalists with Jeffrey fruit and
Suzanne coddle is co-editor of a lot
more
the contributor to many edited volumes
and also author of dozens of journal
articles so it's a great pleasure to
have him here and he has also published
extensively on the topic today media
rankings media indicators and cross
comparisons of them he has many prizes
and distinctions just read a few of them
he's the recipient of the distinguished
research award of the Ohio State
University the Presidential Award and
the Krieg bomb award of the Association
for education journalism and mass
communication the Harold L Nelson
awarded the School of Journalism mass
communication University of Wisconsin
amongst others so it's a great pleasure
to have professor Becker here dr. Karen
Carla Kerr is senior research and
managing editor of freedom of the press
survey at Freedom House here in New York
this is the freedom of the press an
annual index that tracks trends in media
freedom worldwide she coordinates the
research ratings in editorial process
for the index and also writes a number
of the country reports in addition she
led the development of the methodology
for and coordinated the pilot addition
of a new index of internet and digital
media freedom published in april two
thousand nine very apropos given our
discussions about what facebook and
twitter did or did not do in Egypt and
in Tunisia lately maybe we can get into
that and she regularly serves as a
spokesperson for freedom house on media
issues amongst a lot of the research
she's done in many parts of the world
she's traveled extensively in Asia and
Africa and prior she was an editor at
The Economist Intelligence Unit and also
served as a consultant Human Rights
Watch she also holds a PhD in Indian
history from Cambridge University in
so we're delighted to have her and then
and Nelson incredibly distinguished in
both areas professor Nelson also teaches
here at the School of International and
public affairs teaches new media in
development communications and she
specializes in the area of international
media development and she has been an
analyst and evaluator practitioner in
the field she consults for many leading
us foundations and also was executive
director of the Committee to Protect
Journalists so she understands the topic
very well she's written extensively on
media conflict Human Rights a war
correspondent Latin America reported
from East Europe and Asia with work
appearing in New York Times the Los
Angeles Times Harper's the BBC her
writing has won six awards including the
Livingston award for international
reporting but I hadn't realized is that
Anna's also widely produced playwright
and screenwriter for 2001 play the guys
deals with the post 9-11 experience has
been produced throughout the US and in
14 countries and the screenplay became a
2002 feature film starring Sigourney
Weaver and Nancy LaPaglia she's a
graduate of Yale University a member of
the Council on Foreign Relations in the
recipient of a 2005 coogan hon
fellowship for work on media and Nazi
Germany welcome to you all so what we'll
do is we'll have each speaker go about
20 minutes in the presentation 15 or 20
minutes and then we will open it up for
discussion and Q&A from the audience
after that please note that everything
today is on the record so if you decide
to ask a question you know please state
your affiliation and will
recorded for a historical record so
welcome thank you Alex for the very kind
introduction it's truly a pleasure and
truly an honor to be here at the
Harriman Institute and to join my two
colleagues in this panel I look forward
to learning from them and learning from
those of you in the audience and I hope
I can contribute a little bit to the
dialogue the politics of international
media rankings the title of this
presentation today is a topic of great
interest to me and that particular
configuration that is the politics of
the ranking I think is particularly
interesting question to pose I apologize
to Karen for this she knows the story
but I thought I would start by telling a
little bit about how I first got
interested in the rankings and as a
media scholar media freedom freedom of
the press and freedom of the media is
obviously something that's almost
throughout my 40-year career have been
of value and interest and I I think
probably from very early years of the
Freedom House measures I was aware of of
those measures and had at least some
passing interest in them but my interest
became acute nearly 10 years ago now
when I was asked by John bear who was
then the director of research at the
knight Foundation in Miami if he if I
thought that there was some work that
could be done to validate and
critically examine the indicators with
the goal of using these indicators in
evaluation work the foundation was
interested in knowing what the impact
the media assistance projects were in
particularly the post-1990 period and
was interested in learning whether these
indicators could be used as a way of
determining whether the media assisted
invest assistance investment was
producing an outcome in terms of higher
quality more independent media and of
course the ultimate goal is to
understand whether the media played some
role in the furtherance of
democratization so I confess that I was
skeptical about the indicators when I
first started to look at them I saw them
as embedded in a political process and
not the outcome of scientific inquiry
and I was concerned that that political
process contaminated them and in fact
would limit the utility of the
indicators my my view has in fact
changed rather markedly over time in
fact a change rather quickly as we
started working on an assessment of the
evaluators so what I hope to explain to
you in my time today is why that's the
case and talk to you about some of the
research that we have done to look at
the indicators so what my colleague
tutor Vlad and our students have done is
subject the press freedom indices to
standard analysis using the criteria of
reliability and validity and this is
obviously rather straightforward but
it's something that had not been done
as far as we know in any systematic way
before we began to ask that question we
focused primarily on the Freedom House
measure which is the oldest and current
is going to give you a little background
on it for those of you who don't know
too much about it we also looked at the
reporters without borders / put her son
frontiers measure which is I think safe
to say was developed in part as a
response to the prominence of and
presumed bias of the American are the
American bias of the American indicators
and we've also had looked at measures
that have been developed subsequently by
I Rex an NGO or Washington we also did
look at data gathered by the Committee
to Protect Journalists although I'm not
going to talk about that here today and
more recently we have looked at the
indicator from the African media
barometer project which is interesting
because it was developed in Africa by
African scholars with the attempt with
the attempt to develop an indigenous
measure not necessarily reflective of
the concerns of NGOs such as those in
Paris in Washington
so the first question we asked was of
the reliability of the measures and what
we found is that the in fact for all of
these indicators they are reliable
across time and as would be expected the
reliability decreases in a systematic
fashion across time that is the
year-to-year correlations are much
higher than they are as one moves across
time the obvious expectation if the
measures are going to first reliably or
consistently measure a phenomenon and
then reflect change we also found that
in the case in which there are
sub-indices that is for freedom house
and for irex that the internal
dimensions are internally consistent and
yet not identical so they pick up some
additional meaning through the sub
indices in the case of the African media
barometer we could not look at measures
across time because it's a relatively
new indicator but we have shown that
that indicator although it was developed
to be a distinct from the Western
indicators in fact correlates very
highly with those Western indicators in
the time period for which the data are
available we also have made some
preliminary i would say rather simple
attempts that validation via hypothesis
testing or construct validation we have
used the Freedom House measure to look
at
the nature of change in the areas of the
world where change should have been
dramatic and keep periods of time we
looked at the way the measure changed as
Soviet Union dissolved and in fact it
meaningfully reflects that change and we
also looked at the Warsaw Pact countries
as they became more independent and
moved into the Western sphere and again
the Freedom House measure was our focus
because it's the only one that existed
through that period of time and it
accurately reflects the expected change
period we also have been working with a
hypothesis that we have that comes out
of the competition literature
particularly the media competition
literature we have hypothesized that
there are high levels of competition in
a media environment is dysfunctional
from the point of view of the media
product it is probably functional and it
ways in which economist look at
competition that is is probably the case
the stronger media products survive but
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
products that survive are those which
are advantageous from the point of view
of democratic development we hypothesize
that high levels of competition should
be associated with low levels of press
performance and we certainly were
expecting that the relationship if not
what if it were not cover lynnie or at
least would not be a linear positive
relationship and to test that hypothesis
we use measures from I Rex as the
sub-index that IRS I Rex has it focuses
on journalistic performance and the data
are largely supportive of the
expectation
we've also tried to build some simple
theoretical statements about the
relationship of press freedom and
democratization we have a simple model
which reflects I think the assumptions
that exists both in the academic
literature and in the media assistance
area and we tried to we have tried to
simply lay out the premises into a very
very Elementary model but part of the
goal is to move away from simply
methodological assessment and move into
the area more theoretical assessment of
the indices we have a chapter coming out
look at Peter Lang with Peter lining the
series that I edited that contains our
premises about what the relationship
between media and dependents ought to be
a relationship between media systems and
media and dependence ought to be and
more importantly what the relationship
between media independence and
democratization should be and I can say
as a important side that Jack Snyder's
were focusing on the role that the media
have played in some very disruptive
environments particularly Rwanda I think
is particularly important in terms of
understanding the complexity of media
and dependence and its potential role
and democratization and out of as a
result of that where we have tried to
argue that you must have a number of
conditions for media independence and
freedom to produce Democratic outcome
and again the work of objects nighters
been particularly important there's
emerging literature on particularly
Rwanda as you probably know that treats
the case of median dependence there is a
very important case study more
importantly more recently excuse me we
have turned our attention to public
opinion as a means of validating media
freedom and media independence measures
these indicators originally recalled
press freedom I'm trying to use media
freedom as the more appropriate term but
historically and I think even today
they're called press freedom measures
that is in the case of rsf and Freedom
House now there are two related but I
think separable reasons why public
opinion is worth examining in
relationship to media freedom indices
the first is the validity reason that is
aletta valuators and all of these
indicators are based on the work of
elites who try to assess the medium that
aletta valuators might simply get it
wrong and it's important to have data
from the people who are using the media
every day the second reason is that even
if the elite evaluate evaluate errs have
it right I think it's worth asking the
question as to whether or not
an assessment of the media system would
not be more complete if it also included
measures from the public that is to say
shouldn't it be important if we want to
understand a media system to know that
the public also shares the view of the
elite evaluate errs that is thinks that
the media are free and has confidence in
them and it would it not be the case
that a system that was evaluated as free
or independent from the point of view of
the evaluators who largely focus on
constraints would be a less meritorious
system than one but all but did not have
the support of the public would be a
less meritorious system than one that
had both elite and public assessments of
freedom so what we argue then is are
wanting to argue and what we were trying
to look at with our data is the question
as to whether or not we should not build
into in the future into these indices
public assessments of trust and
confidence and I'm going to show you
some data that speak to that point the
second second argument then I think is a
rather important one and I'll turn come
to it in the
come back to it in the end
turn a little bit now to some of our
public opinion data and that's what I
will focus on through the remaining time
of my presentation where we started was
with a couple very small data sets we
don't have the resources to deserve to
feel public opinion surveys around the
world in order to ask people about them
their assessments of the media so we
have been searching for our datasets
that speak to that point and we found a
BBC World Service pulled back in 2007
from 14 countries and you can see that
the questions there I actually was going
to read that question to you but I tried
to read it when I was preparing and I
realized how contorted it is and so I'll
let you to read it to yourself to see
the complexity the question it is in
fact scored in a reverse way as its
shown there and what we looked at is the
relationship between that measure and
the Freedom House measures we use both
Pearson and spearmen Pearson's R in
speare Monroe you can see that it's a
relatively modest correlation of only
point 31 in the Pearson case and point
23 the Spearman road case probably the
more appropriate case given the small
number
we also found the data set from world
public opinion in 2008 with a measure
that I think is much more satisfactory
it says how much freedom does the media
have in your country a lot not very much
none at all and here the Pearson R is
actually quite robust point 8 1 spearman
point 7 6 because we had these two data
sets and they were not showing the same
thing we took the eight cases where they
data were in fact the question was posed
in those same eight countries and
there's no relationship between them so
we would like to conclude and we think
we have some data that will allow us to
conclude that the BBC measure is not a
particularly good one we had the good
fortune of being in touch with some
people at gallop working on the gallop
world poll which as you probably know is
now filled it in more than 150 countries
are
entities around the world some of them
are not countries Puerto Rico's a
separate country in the Gallup poll but
so be it any rate 150 different units in
which the polls conducted and there are
core of items that are used across all
of the Gallup world poll surveys in some
countries there's the polls that filled
it more than once a year it's been fully
funded fielded I think as many as six or
eight times in some countries and
sometimes it's one or two and in most
cases is one time a year but there are a
core number of items that they try to
use in all of those countries now they
that they can't use them in all cases
because in some cases they're simply not
allowed by the government in some cases
their field organization won't use them
says that they can't actually be asked
but what we were able to do is to get an
item into the core for 2010 that says to
the media in this country have a lot of
freedom or not we actually suggest that
the world public opinion item to them
but this is the variant that they were
willing to feel they say that many of
the countries the surveyors surveyor
organizations in the field staff very
very strong preference for either or
items that this is the variant it came
out so in 2010 that item appeared for
the first time in the core and we have
data now for more than a hundred
countries but I got the data for about
50 of them only two days ago so we have
data for 48 that I can show you here
today and I'm just going to show you a
series of scatter plots you can if you
get really good eyes
can see some of the countries there but
what we're looking at here and this
first chart is the relationship between
the rsf voters Without Borders measure
and press freedom of press freedom of
2010 and the Gallup data for 2010
obviously at this point we have no idea
whether what kind of lag might be
appropriate we only have data for one
year in terms of the Gallup data so we
looked at the 10 by 10 relationship and
the R is negative 43 which is a positive
43 we have respected the Preferences of
rsf and Freedom House for negative
scoring and consequently a negative is a
positive in in the analysis and you can
see the pattern you can see some
outliers and I'm just going to go very
quickly through this but this is the 9 x
10 relationship that is taking press
freedom measure from 2009 with the
Gallup data for 2010 again the only year
for which we have data and although we
will have more that item is remained in
the core for 2011 and so we filled it
throughout this year as well and the
correlation is very comfortable putting
44 so a modest correlation we're
encouraging is the correlation with the
Freedom House measure from 2009 with the
Gallup measure from 2010
and we're waiting on Karen's report for
2010 to see what that happens when we go
year by year it makes some sense that
there would be a lag but as I said we
have no theoretical argument about what
that lag should be you can see there are
some interesting outliers and these
would be the cases in which we would say
that some measure of public opinion
would contribute to the understanding of
press freedom that is if you look at
Cambodia Lithuania these are falling
down at the top and the bottom there's a
discrepancy they're falling off the axis
and so the public is disagreeing with
the elites in those cases now we
conclude lymon airily that this is
further evidence that there's a link
between elite evaluations of the media
and public assessments so there's some
evidence of superiority of the Freedom
House measure that comes from this I'm
sure the colonel to be unhappy to hear
that but she's heard that before in fact
that maybe we haven't sent you this
paper yet
but at any rate the differences in isn't
great but you know it's in the right
direction and there are still some
important limitations as a small number
of countries and Europe was not in the
set the were missing the 2010 measure
from Freedom House we're relying on the
single measure from Gallup it's all that
we could get into the core we felt often
blessed to get that in and but because
we're dealing with a single measure
there's no way to standardize that
measure so we have no sense about
national differences in terms of
response patterns or codes use of the
codes and we really haven't had the
chance yet to look at differences in the
political environment which may have
some impact on that relationship but I'm
going to talk to you in a moment about
some cases where we have done that so as
I said we have data now for about
another 50 countries we will be
analyzing those we hope that presenting
a paper about them and Miss thimble this
summer we
we've been really really fortunate to
have a chance to work with Gallup honest
I'm on with tutor and I are on the
advisory board for gallup world poll for
their media questions and they're very
very thankful that we've had that
opportunity we've been working with a
woman named Cynthia English and she's
been an author of the work that I just
spoke about and the work I'm going to
speak about now so I want to acknowledge
her contribution she's a research
scientist with gallop in Nebraska so I'm
going to just close by going very
quickly through another data set in
which we are looking at a confidence
measure gallop in that core up until two
thousand eleven had this cluster of
items do you have confidence that each
of the following or not military
judicial system of courts national
government health care medical systems
to financial institutions or banks
religious organizations and integrity of
the media now they don't include all of
those items in all countries but usually
it's the cases that they will have 73 is
common in some of the countries again
they can ask questions in certain cases
what we have is data from about a
hundred two or three countries for two
thousand seven eight nine and we will
have 2010 that item is it was in the
Corps in 2010 but has been bumped for
2011 we haven't analyzed anything from
2010 yet but what we have done in this
case is we have standardized the
confidence measure across the set that
is we are looking now not at the
absolute level of confidence but a
confidence relative to the other
institutions and i'm going to show you
just five scatter plots and the first
one is zero order relationship and it
shows you nothing and in fact it's
consistent with what has been done with
analysis gallop first did and we did
with two thousand five and six whether
were small number countries at the zero
order there is surprisingly no
relationship between confidence in the
media and the level of political freedom
we look for ways in which we might
disentangle that relationship we thought
there might be a variable masking the
relationship we were hopeful that was
the case we saw it we looked at several
measures we were encouraged by Gallup to
look at this particular item although we
looked at others most of it says in your
opinion how many people in your country
if any are afraid to openly express
their political views a gallup likes the
question because they're not asking
about yourself so you get away from this
pride or unwillingness to say that
you're constrained you're pushing it off
on somebody else but you're saying yeah
people around here are really afraid and
we use that to divide our hundred
countries 110 countries into four
clusters roughly quartiles to look at
the relationship between press freedom
and confidence in those four different
political arenas now again it's negative
scored here so positive is a negative
and so when fear of political expression
is very low such as you can see here in
New Zealand Denmark Netherlands
you essence in that cluster there's
actually a negative relationship between
press freedom and confidence okay when
again the positive is a negative because
of the reverse scoring when the fear of
political expression is a little bit
more but still there's not much of it
you have a little bit less of a
relationship of the negative
relationship but still one existing when
the fear becomes higher the relationship
turns negative and stays negative
although it's a little bit more
mitigated in the high fear environment
so that variable the fear has masked the
original relationship and we do in fact
then find that there is a relationship
between confidence in the media and
press freedom we've used the reporters
the Freedom House measures here we also
use reporters without borders the
relationships are much the same we've
used spearman's and Pearson's doesn't
really change the picture very much so
we think the analysis provide further
evidence of the validity of the measures
of press freedom by leaking them up to
public opinion they also show the value
of exploring the relationship of media
system characteristics with other
characteristics of society and including
public opinion measures and we think the
undertaking will be complex but a
systematic measure of media systems
probably should include both elite
measures
as the current Freedom House rsf
measures I Rex measures do as well as
public opinion assessments if you have
one copies of the paper you can either
go to the kroc center website there's a
conference paper section in our number
of papers you'll recognize them by
titles I think and you also also could
just send me an email message and I'd be
glad to to send you whichever papers
were of interest and with that I thank
you for your attention and look forward
to hearing from my colleagues
thanks everyone um hopefully everyone
can hear me okay and I'd like to thank
the heroine center and Alex and Jack for
inviting me to speak today I've tried to
make my presentation a little bit
different than normal because Lee and I
keep speaking on panels together so he's
he's very bored with my print my
standard uh talk by now I think so I've
tried to UM to focus in in this
presentation I'll start off by black
widows short overview of our freedom has
index for those of you who are may not
know too much about it but then I wanted
to focus mostly on looking at the impact
of the index how it's used and sort of
some of the media coverage how
governments respond to it and some of
the more practical sort of day-to-day
things as a looking at this topic as a
practitioner rather than as an academic
first as a sort of overview of the whole
field of media indicators I just wanted
to to clarify that the freedom has index
as well as other indices are not sort of
surveys as people might think of them in
terms of let's say going out and
surveying hundreds of respondents in
each country and then having numerical
ratings that are based on surveys so the
freedom has index as well as all other
indices um that will be discussing and
Lee has mentioned these already are
basically we all produce quantitative
data but it is produced through
qualitative means I would say and so we
produce these numerical ratings but they
are not in many cases tied to specific
indicators or data points for example
let's say looking at the number of news
outlets in a country or as I said a
traditional survey respondents their
numerical scores are given on the basis
of
expert judgment on the basis of
questions asked in the methodology of
each index and each index has a slightly
different way of going about this which
I can get into a little bit more on the
QA of people are interested looking at
the field as a whole I think we can
divide the indices out there into two
basic categories and one is press
freedom indices and these were developed
primarily for advocacy purposes I put
Freedom House in rsf into this category
we both cover the legal environment for
media political issues and economic
issues it as part of our methodology
questions rsf i would say focus is a
little bit more on the political
category and particularly on attacks and
violence against journalists so when you
look at the discrepancies between our
ratings for certain countries i would
say probably eighty or ninety percent
will fall roughly in the same category
and the major discrepancies are really
seeing for countries which have very
high murder rates against journalists so
countries such as Russia Sri Lanka the
Philippines will will measure a much
worse on on the rsf index than our index
on the other side we have media
sustainability or development indicators
and these were developed setting of
slightly different set your more as a
diagnostic tool and under this category
I'd put I rex's emedia sustainability
index the newer Africa and Asia media
barometers which as Lee mentioned are
sort of locally produced and
conceptualized and then the newest one
is and that UNESCO doesn't actually
produce numbers but they do produce a
new set of studies called it's are
looking at a media media velopment
indicator so they are looking at
a lot of the same questions but they
don't provide numbers they provide
narrative reports i would say these
indicators focus on the legal and
political but they also focus a lot more
on issues of economic sustainability and
there's also greater attention given to
issues of media professionalism which we
do not cover so much in our index
turning specifically to focus on the
Freedom House index just a few basics we
have been conducting the the process for
this will be the 31st year this year so
it is the longest-running index
currently we produce net analytical
reports and numerical ratings and it's
196 countries and territories this year
we will be expanding and we have
expanded in recent years to to add in
countries like Kosovo probably next year
South Sudan will be another edition so
so it is expanding all the time and we
are one of we are one of the main
country organizations that does both
country reports for every country as
well as as numerical indicators which
are which are linked together rsf
focuses more on the numbers when they
put out their index built they they
don't really have narrative reports that
are directly tied into those numbers in
our index we give each country of status
designation of free partly free or not
free we give them a numerical rating
based on our set of methodology
questions on a 0-200 scale and then we
also rank them on a global scale so that
started a few years ago and end
countries are ranked on that level as
well we also produce an annual map of
press freedom which has the country's
colored according to status and that's
one of the things I think that we're
best known for and is one of the things
we use as a as an advocacy tool
turning to what the freedom has index
measures and what we really try and
capture with our methodology questions
are two main sort of baskets I would say
one is the media's ability to operate
freely and without fear of repercussions
and the ability of a public to access
diverse and independent sources of news
information we try and cover a very wide
range of factors we look at the role of
the state as well as at non-state actors
we look at impact of media owners and
editors and surgeon groups and pretty
much any other type of political
economic or societal force that could
impact media content or practice so we
really try and measure the entire
enabling environment for media freedom
rather than focusing and more on the
things like attacks and we divide this
into legal political and economic
categories the index also does cover at
the moment print broadcast and
increasingly internet and new media
freedom and we do sort of try and update
our methodology and tweak it a little
bit to take into account the changing
media environment in many countries in
terms of our exact scoring process as I
said we have a zero to 100 scale and
it's negatively I guess done so higher
numbers indicate less freedom and the
closer you get to zero the better the
better you are in terms of your media
freedom score currently are a set of 20
23 methodology questions we divide them
into these three categories as you can
see the the categories are pretty evenly
weighted although political is slightly
more and on 0 to 40 point scale and as
we mentioned we do also divide
we have we have sub I guess totals for
each of these three categories so
scholars can look at our overall
numerical rating for country as well as
the ratings for these three categories
within our methodologies each question
that we have receives a different
weighting so broader questions
concerning editorial control for example
and violence and attacks are weighted
the most those questions a country could
get a potential score of between 0 and
10 points I'm specific questions receive
the least weight and in countries let's
say would get a score between 0 and 2
points so we have questions in the legal
category on freedom of information
legislation and on Lyle and those are
much more specific questions a full set
of our methodology questions and all the
issues that we look at are available
online of people are interested on me in
the methodology and then based on the
the numerical score we as I said give
this category breakdown of free partly
free and not free
um in terms of looking at how the scores
and reports are produced we we have
analysts who usually right between three
and six country reports they do all the
research they write the draft reports
and they also do the draft scoring for
each country I would say about a third
at the moment of written by Freedom
House staff and two-thirds are written
by consultants and many are based in the
United States but some are based
internationally either in the countries
or regions that they cover um once the
analysts actually right now is the time
of year when the analysts are all
working on their draft we have we then
in March hold review meetings for each
region where we gather all the analysts
and our regional advisors together and
we talked about the scores and go
through all the scoring and then we
reach consensus about what the score
should be for each country and then we
also after that go in go into an
extensive fact-checking and editorial
process in house to to complete the
final product
I'll turn now to how the all the indices
are used this and this relates to
Freedom House as well as some of the
other indices although I'm talking more
hear about how because I know more about
how our own index is used so i'll divide
us into several categories one is as a
research tool because of the extensive
time period and data set of the Freedom
House index it's extensively used by
academics in order to run correlations
between media issues and other themes
such as corruption economic development
political transition number of different
issues it's also being used currently by
the World Bank as part of its governance
indicated data sets in terms of the
advocacy uses of the index which is I
think the reason why we started it as
well as rsf we're widely quoted by media
outlets both at the time that we release
the annual index in May and and
throughout the year if there's an issue
that develops in a certain country that
many many local outlets will pick up our
index um it's used extensively by
activists and countries they will cite
our index on court cases and when
they're trying to push for reform or to
highlight issues within their country at
sort of an international well respected
standard indicator and it can provide a
way for both local activists and for us
as a westerner international NGO to
engage with governments
further uses of the index are as a
diagnosed not a diagnostic tool it's
used by donors and media development
organizations so groups like USAID
differed use the indices to track the
success and impact of their own media
programs and this is somewhat
problematic usage on which I can get
into more in the queue and I if people
are interested the broadcasting Board of
Governors and Voice of America use the
index to determine their broadcasting
priorities for overseas us-funded
broadcasting the Millennium Challenge
corporation also uses the index to
informants foreign aid decisions the
corporate sector uses the index as a
diagnostic tool as well and groups like
Google and Yahoo use our reports to
inform their own internal Human Rights
impact assessments and this is obviously
getting I think more important as they
as those types of companies get even
more prominence in terms of what's going
on in the world today and the
information flows globally these talked
a lot about gallop but Gallup has also
been using a freedom has data a little
bit more and academics such as they've
been using the two sets of data to look
at these are correlations I won't talk
too much about that because we heard
about it
firmly um so one example of the impact
is in terms of us government-funded
foreign broadcasting um I'm just
mentioning a few cases from the last few
years that I know about this was several
years ago probably about five years ago
but the broadcasting Board of Governors
used Freedom House index numbers to
justify cutting language services by
radio free europe/radio Liberty to the
Baltic States in Central Europe and
their main argument was that these
countries scores were the same or
similar to the score for the United
States and there was a lot of pushback
from people some people and you know in
the countries but and I actually got
called about it and people were asking
me so that was that was sort of an
interesting an interest in case um this
past year of renewed funding for us
broadcasting to Asia which is Radio Free
Asia was justified in a bill proposed by
senator lugar in the Senate and end a
major part of the bill used Freedom
House scores to talk about the low press
freedom ratings for a number of Asian
countries and was used as a
justification for continuing and
expanding RFA services to the region
another example of impact concerns the
Millennium Challenge account and this
has affected our press freedom survey as
well as some of the other Freedom House
indices the MCA is a US government aid
instrument that Awards money based on a
set of performance indicators including
human rights and good governance Freedom
House media freedom indicators and our
other indexes such as freedom in the
world are one of our some of the factors
that feed into making these judgments
and there have been several cases of
countries being denied aid packages due
to declines and press freedom and that's
been explicitly stated so both for the
Gambia and Sri Lanka these countries
were denied aid packages based on
declines in their numerical scores and
our index the use of freedom has scores
by the MCC has led I would say over the
last five years or so too much more
attention being given to our ratings by
governments
I'm looking at that a little more but
the what that's meant for us on the
ground I'm and on a daily basis is that
we're getting many more requests by gun
from government officials for meetings
to discuss the ratings and also offers
to provide us with positive information
reforms that are going on you know
telling us it's not so bad that we don't
have the information right things like
that and so our mostly it's our
executive staff but sometimes the rest
of us get pulled into these meetings to
uh to hear from them to try and defend
what we've said and in some cases I
think that they're more interested in a
dialogue and some you know they're not
really interested in that i love but
they're still trying to get their money
from the mca i would say mostly this
concerns mid-ranger cusp countries such
as Jordan Morocco Armenian Cameroon and
it's the worst of the worst performers
are not really the ones trying to engage
in dialogue with us but some i would say
i mean we had a meeting actually with
the foreign minister of the maldives
this was when they were trying to push
for reforms in the Maldives and they
were actually very interested in hearing
about what we would recommend or how
they could improve their score looking
at media coverage which is also very
interesting and it's been expanding over
over the last few years there are
definitely some typical patterns that we
see over here some of which are quite
amusing in some countries for example
media coverage is used as I mostly about
state-owned media to drive attention to
a neighbor's bad score so we have a case
of Armenia and Azerbaijan who are still
locked in mortal combat and usually
every year we find Azerbaijani media
outlets I'm putting out stories about
freedom house has raided our media is
not free and not not really drawing any
attention to what their own score is
which is actually worse than our median
score I'll show you a copy in a minute
actually let me I can go forward right
now so this is a screenshot of a news AZ
they usually put this kind of thing out
every year focusing on what our score is
for Armenia which is quite funny
hopefully you guys can see some of the
text look Russia's another very
interesting case where they are actively
trying to discredit freedom house and
make make us look silly in there in the
news coverage that comes out from Russia
more more from the state-controlled
media definitely there are actually some
more independent outlets in Russia that
do that have used our index to to talk
about what the declines have been in
Russia but um looking at the estate
control media coverage it there are
three definite themes that usually come
out one is about freedom house being a
US government controlled entity and an
instrument of u.s. foreign policy one is
sort of looking at our the broad
category designations and the fact that
you know they say well Freedom House
rates Russia the same as North Korea how
can that be that's ridiculous that means
freedom house's is silly and then the
third thing they often try and do is is
my comments like you know Russia's rank
the same as this African country how
ridiculous is that how we could be the
same as an African country so this is a
typical article by Pravda sort of going
on about how freedom house is a US
government controlled and
and things like that if people are
interested in these I can can send
copies in case you can't see them OOP on
the positive side i would say that
fridley the Freedom House index is used
by both local media and civil society
groups to highlight declines and media
freedom or new threats in their own
countries and in the past year we saw
two two big issues which in which our
index was really picked up and the
Freedom House ratings were were
highlighted in terms of local media
coverage so one is in South Africa where
we actually downgraded South Africa to
partly free in last year's index based
on things that had already been
happening and then there were two big
threats in South Africa this year one
was the protection of Information bill
and then there's the a government idea
to set up a media council which would be
sort of a statutory regulation of the
media these two developments have been
loudly and vociferously opposed by the
South African media and by press freedom
groups both local and international and
a lot of them picked up the fact that we
had already downgraded on South Africa
and and you know that we had these
concerns so that was a very positive use
of our of our ratings and numbers and
has actually led to stalling on both of
these measures by the South African
government similarly this year I think
that started in around June but hungry
past a very restrictive media bill and
in several stages which was finally
passed in September there was a lot of
attention to this by Freedom House other
press freedom groups and the EU
sustained and you know this is actually
led I think to the government recently
to promise amending the new law so
that's been very positive but so so both
of these I think are sort of positive
and
in the use of our index local press
freedom organizations also use our
scores as part of their advocacy work so
in Thailand a local press freedom group
submitted it was actually part of a
libel case against an editor this was
four or five years ago and they
submitted to the court as part of the
case in amicus curiae brief and they
cited our freedom has index as showing
that there had been a huge decline in
Thailand's press freedom and so that was
submitted as part of the evidence to the
court last year the Hong Kong
Journalists Association used our
downgrade of Hong Kong mayor before to
highlight that in their own annual
report and to try and draw attention to
these issues in Hong Kong and this is a
screenshot of from Thailand which which
cited are cited our
this is a hungry one
this is our article on an African media
which was using our map and our index so
so yeah so it's I think they were both
positive and a negative uses and impacts
just a few summarizing thoughts and
general much of the media coverage as
well as critiques from governments or
individuals are of our broader category
designations so they'll say well how can
this country be ranked as not free and
sort of looking at the big picture in
most cases this happens without much
knowledge of or interested in the the
numerical score or in our methodology
questions and how a country would end up
at a students as certain score rating
while the category designations and the
map are useful for advocacy purposes and
getting the big picture at a glance I
would definitely recommend more
knowledge of the methodology than actual
numerical scores and our scoring process
when people are using the index to make
more nuanced decisions for example
regarding funding or the impact of
programs or obviously for academic
research so I will um I will end it
there to leave more time for for
questions in queue time and we do have
maps and booklets over there if anyone
would like to grab a copy after the
session and I'm available on email as
well people have questions after thank
you
so I don't have a PowerPoint my name is
Anne Nelson I teach here at CPAP and I
about 20-some years ago was presented
with the challenge of helping to evolve
some press freedom indicators in my
position at the as the director of the
Committee to Protect Journalists and I
have to say that this field has come in
awfully long ways in a relatively short
time 20 years in my life is short let's
think about where we were 20 or 30 years
ago it was really very much the
atmosphere of the Cold War and we had
really a sense that the West was free
the East was not and the rest of the
world didn't entirely exist and so
working with that premise was very very
challenging and at the Committee to
Protect Journalists we were very much a
kind of ambulance service for
journalists we would get reports that a
journalist was imprisoned tortured
killed in a given country and our job
was to try to help them physically as
quickly as possible and so that was
really how we began as we went along we
found that somewhat to our surprise that
we were gathering data and we would have
lists of the actions we had taken and we
would categorize it with our primitive
computer systems of the mid-1980s and
say well this data might have some kind
of value and we started getting more and
more inquiries from academics and press
representatives saying well what does
your data mean so so we really were
repressed by the audience for our
information to codify it and interpret
it
now this caused some problems because
people would say let's look at your
computer printout and eight journalists
were killed in the Philippines but 20
journalists were imprisoned in Hungary
so which is freer the Philippines or
hungry and we'd say well how many people
in prison equal how many people killed
we can't make any sense of that that
that equation right and a lot of the
press the abuses of press freedom that
we found were in other categories
newspapers confiscated in Singapore all
right nuisance libel suits right so
these were things that would chill press
freedom they had an effect we we
protested them we recorded them but it
wasn't a situation where we could put
this data head-to-head and and create a
kind of hierarchy so on my watch is
director one thing that we did was take
these relatively primitive computer
printouts of that were incident reports
they almost look like a police blotter
we said all right well let's flesh them
out let's do a little bit more
storytelling so that we can try to
figure out what what they mean so for
example if if a journalist was beaten by
police in a demonstration that had one
context if the police went to his home
and dragged him out of his home with his
family and beat him there that was much
more intentional and you could read the
incident and and start to draw a greater
conclusion from the patterns of abuses
however people would say well if it
doesn't show up on your list then it's
fine well Saudi Arabia look great North
Korea was perfect because there was
really no press at that point
functioning so there were no abuses no
journalists who were really operating
independently enough to get into trouble
it wasn't possible so no one could look
at the attacks on the Press report in
the late 1980s and come up with any kind
of a sense of hierarchy of press freedom
and we always warned people not to do
that that's not what that report was
nonetheless especially in the media
people started doing it themselves and
pushing us for rankings and my approach
to that being very reluctant to issue
reports on how many prisoners make a
murder was to to create a list that we
call countries of concern and so we
would highlight a list I believe we
started out with 10 or 12 countries
where we said these are countries where
bad things are going on and possibly
where there is a rate of change it gets
a little boring to report on North Korea
because nothing ever happened in North
Korea to that was made the press very
worth discussing rather than deploring
but there were other countries where
there would be trends and patterns and
events that would be quite quite drastic
often these were linked to political
occasions so if you had a lot of
political violence if you had an
insurgency that often correspond it with
an upsurge of journalists deaths and you
could see that very clearly over the
years in countries like the Philippines
countries like Colombia and sometimes we
talk among ourselves as researchers and
say it's almost like this pinball
machine where certain countries light up
from year to year you might not draw
certain conclusions from which countries
showed up on that list for example the
Philippines traditionally has a free
press in many under many metrics because
it has a very lively press it reports
very critically at the government and a
business interest
has a lot of issues but the country has
often had a tradition of extreme
violence against the press so so we
tried to come up with means of
storytelling I suppose that would say
let's look at societies in their own
terms but have a set of absolutes that
have to do with our reactions to press
conditions and obviously murder and
torture we're very very high on our list
we condemn those it got very tricky in
in other areas and we really had to
struggle with issues of cultural
relativism this certainly applied to our
colleagues one of the shocking moments
in my career was getting a copy of the
equivalent of our attacks of an
oppressed report from the international
organization of journalists in Prague in
1988 and what they had done was
plagiarized our entire report except
they took out Nicaragua Cuba the Soviet
Union and the and the other countries in
the block they just removed them but
everything else was was word for word so
I
I protested this event to them and they
apologized and then things changed it
was also interesting to be present at
the formation of reporters of montia our
reporters without borders and that was
born as something called the
l'observatoire in montpelier and their
research methodology was based on
surveying correspondence and this is
noted in Lee Becker's excellent paper
that i just read before coming tonight
that i highly recommend one thing that
we noted was that the correspondence
that they interviewed were from johns
france-presse okay well what do we know
about that French people like to read
about former French colonies so we found
that the documentation of francophone
Africa was much more comprehensive than
it was an Anglophone Africa and it's not
that you would necessarily look at that
and say it's a political bias it is
simply a logistical data gathering
reality and I'm think that they're
probably heavily reliant on John's
france-presse to this day one thing that
we did at the Committee to Protect
Journalists was really try to interview
a wide wide range of both foreign
correspondents and local journalists in
every country that we covered so that
including as Ron's france-presse but
also you know many wire agencies and
local and international press
organizations that was that was an
interesting development we also found
very interesting variations in in
metrics now the killed list was always
the one that the media responded to and
one thing that you'll find with all of
these reports is that you'll find some
disparity in lists of journalists killed
in a given year if you if you drill down
into that data you'll find that
different standards are used and at the
Committee to Protect Journalists we
tried to restrict it to people that we
felt were killed pursuing their
profession and in some way or other
because they were pursuing their
profession that may sound obvious but we
would get into discussions heated
discussions with colleagues at other
organizations who would record
journalists killed in the pursuit of
their professions but for what might be
accidental reasons so the example I
remember was the journalist who was
speeding to cover a story and ran a
stoplight and got you know had I had a
collision well he was on the job but
there was no suggestion that the car
that hit him knew he was at journal is
going to cover a story it was a traffic
accident right so that was the kind of
data that was gathered by the more union
oriented organizations as opposed to the
press freedom organizations so as you
see it really may start out sounding
simple but very quickly it became not
simple another issue that we continue to
struggle with is access to participation
even 20 years ago it was difficult to
determine quite often who was a
journalist so we had a case in China
where Chinese dock workers created a
mimeograph news organization
that accompanied to strike and they put
out mamia graft messages and they were
distributed and they were arrested and
they were beaten up they were dock
workers they'd ever made a scent as
professional journalists and we debated
it internally for a while and then we
said well they didn't have the potential
to become journalists under the
political system they were working under
so for our purposes if they were trying
to function as journalists within their
their possibilities we will count them
as journalists and this is something
that I cover in in my recent book red
orchestra about Nazi Germany I describe
a circle of people who did not get a
paycheck from a journalistic
organization they published zombies dot
in Nazi Germany on mimeograph machines
because that's all they could do some of
them were former journalists who had
lost their jobs because of the Nazi
regulations so this gets you into gray
areas of data but I do think that in
order to be honest in evaluating it you
have to admit that these gray areas
exist so one thing that
it's important to think about in looking
at all of these indicators which are
extremely valuable is also how they skew
so quite often what they don't record
are certain audiences that live in media
dark zones of their countries and of the
world these indicators record the kinds
of media that are available to people
who tend to be literate and tend to have
some disposable income and if people do
not belong to that that sector in their
countries they may not really be present
in these assessments who are these
people well in many countries the very
poor in many countries the illiterate in
many countries women in many countries
indigenous peoples and in some countries
you might have indicators that say the
press operates somewhat freely but in a
given language I'm working right now on
a report for the World Association of
newspapers that's looking in media
markets and one of the countries were
studying is Mozambique high rate of
illiteracy and not a terrible record on
media freedom but the newspapers are
published in Portuguese which is only
spoken by a very small minority of the
people so you have this whole world of
indigenous populations who don't really
have representation in a lot of these
these maps they don't create media they
don't consume media and so therefore
their their freedom is not fully
measured within these parameters
it's a lot easier to measure media in
print print stand still it's very
difficult to measure media such as talk
radio and sometimes I think that we get
something of a distorted view of
countries like China because so much of
the energy in in expression may be on on
platforms like talk radio and nobody is
there recording it I don't even think
it's probably possible to record it in
any meaningful way so if we look at the
world of China as defined by the
People's Daily it looks like one picture
if you look at the talk radio
environment of southern China it looks
different and as I said it's not
necessarily a flaw of the metrics it's
but but I think it's important to
acknowledge what we're looking at and of
course the internet raises this problem
to the nth degree so here we have a
methodology that is really advancing in
some ways but does not always take into
account what some people call the bottom
billion in terms of the challenges
moving forward I think that we're going
to be increasingly challenged to define
what is media what is the press and who
is a journalist Egypt showed that to us
many times over for example a lot of us
before the session we're saying we had
our updates on Egypt on facebook and on
twitter because that's where you could
get at the fastest is a facebook group
journalism would a facebook group
reporting on the events in Egypt show up
on a press freedom indicator would it
show up on an Internet freedom indicator
I don't know
I think it's something that we're
probably going to have to wrestle with
and I've written about some of these
issues for the Carnegie reporter in an
article called Arab media two point oh
that that might be interesting for
people it will be more important to
measure what happens with audiences as
we go into interactive media I was just
in Vietnam as as karen was and the
Vietnamese government has installed
software to track users of websites and
so if you log on to a certain website
then eventually the police follow a
cumulative pattern in your traffic and
show up at your door and they can arrest
you does this show up on press freedom
indicators because it's the user not the
producer of the media unless this person
also post comments already there's this
huge world of control that's opening up
at the same time there's another world
that could be regarded as more positive
because you have media for development
being used on a massive scale that
increases literacy increases internet
penetration among the poor among rural
underserved populations and is being
used for rapid poverty alleviation that
is being recorded where is this
happening well the leading countries are
China and Vietnam so here's this paradox
where people who had zero access to
media have access to media for the first
time but they also have it accompanied
by limitations in political expression I
think it's important to look at the
broader picture in that regard I'll
close by saying that within this world
association of newspapers study I think
people here will be fascinated with the
data we got information and survey
material from 222 media managers from 66
countries
one of the striking takeaways as we go
to our final data analysis and the
responses is that the majority of media
managers in developing and emerging
markets said that their biggest obstacle
to their work was not restrictions that
in terms of censorship and government
control it was the absence of data and
development on the business side they
didn't have audit bureau's of
circulation they didn't have advertising
data and they didn't have NGOs who were
coming into these countries and helping
them create these databases to run their
businesses so if they go bankrupt as
they freely express their opinions they
still aren't functioning media so this
is the very earliest pre-publication
stage of this report but my suspicion is
that what people may take away from it
is that this entire approach to metrics
may be coming into a new phase where it
will be broadened to include more
economic and social indicators moving
forward thank you
very thank you very much to all the
panelists so let's let's open up and
take some questions or comments and if
you'd like to use the microphone there
in the meantime I will kick off the
questioning recently I was involved in a
project called who governs the globe and
it was an attempt to wrestle around the
question of who's a global governor who
has authority in this sort of vast
disparate of fabric to make judgments
set standards and so forth and I think
this is most of her Karen but also anime
want to weigh in on this it strikes me
that by being incorporated into the
Millennium Challenge accounts you've
sort of crossed a border a threshold
into as Benedict kingsburg would called
a global administrative law I mean
you're you're formally a governor right
you're formally someone who sets
standards for ways that you didn't 44
uses that you didn't sign up to and my
question would be how his freedom house
and I would and and and and perhaps we
can compare and contrast this with CBJ
how have you handled this this new
designation this new responsibilities
you mentioned the delegations that you
get in and now you have to manage I get
some diplomatic duties how has that
changed you as an organization I think
one of the main things it's done over
the past five or six years I would say
is we and it's been very difficult
because of funding constraints and
personnel constraints and things like
that but we've really tried to increase
the analytical rigor of our work both of
our main surveys
so that's led to several things I would
say a much more detailed editing process
sort of cross checking things like that
we've increased the teams of analysts
for both publications some analysts for
example used to let maybe write ten
countries now it would be more like
three to five so we have people really
honing in on reports the narrative
reports are longer for both publications
as well so they're more detailed they
provide more nuanced analysis in terms
of the the narrative portion I notice a
lot of the press freedom report sizes
have probably doubled or tripled over
the last five or six years and we've
also tried to increase the numbers
increase the length of our ratings
meetings and the number of people
involved in the in the process in terms
of the review process so I've also tried
to for example bring in local voices by
sending out draft reports to local press
freedom organizations as well as much as
I can so I think I think that's one of
the main things we've tried to do is
really improve the the analytical rigor
and the and the detail that we're able
to provide as well so we it sort of put
on us on our toes in terms of trying to
improve what we're doing because we
realized that these these scores are
being used to make very big decisions
about large amounts of money so it's not
just a very theoretical idea of like oh
well this country is getting the score
and that's that's cool you know it
really is having a big impact and we're
trying to sort of make sure that we are
able to step up to the plate and defend
our rating so a government comes and
asks us a question we're able to really
have all the evidence there and make
sure we can defend it
yeah thank you and did you well
certainly the research firepower of this
field has stepped up to an unimaginable
level when i started at CPJ in 1988 we
were three and a half people when I left
in 92 we were 12 and now i believe it's
22 with with additional offices
elsewhere so just just the sheer
research capacity is phenomenal and the
other thing is that you build on on your
learning I mean we are we have all been
part of a chapter of history that's been
about creation of a body of knowledge
and interacting with each other in
international meetings and learning from
each other so so I think that when we go
I haven't been face-to-face with an
angry government minister now for a few
years it's lots of fun and usually I
find that I would find that they were
fairly poorly prepared and that you
could counter their protests with a few
facts and they wouldn't have much to
respond and in fact sometimes you felt
like you were informing them about
problems of their country that they may
not have been aware of so there's almost
an educational element in it as well and
sometimes I think privately you get the
sense that they almost welcome learning
about this org agree with you yeah
no they were just being sent there by
their superiors to voice a complaint but
they may they may actually agree with
you know what is that Jack Jack
Schneider I teach at Columbia so I have
a question about the consequences of
media freedom and so this is I guess
partly a question for Lee is a guy who
has his finger tips on all the data sets
and and is up on all the studies but
it's also partly a question for Karen as
someone who works for an advocacy
organization is advocating improved
media freedom and part of advocacy one
might think would be to make a case that
improving media freedom actually does
good things in the world and so I have
this fist full of questions about
consequences of free media that I don't
know the answer to but that I have maybe
hunches about and so one is what are the
consequences of free or media for media
quality so we normally like to think
that the free or the media the better
the information in the media but we know
that sometimes that's not true so freer
media in burundi leads to more hate
speech or freer media in India leads to
more kind of unprofessional vernacular
vernacular language press outlets where
the quality of the information is I
don't know maybe it's good but maybe
it's it's just rumors what about the
impact of free or media on the political
tenor of the content our freer media
more moderate media or they
radical media the only study that I know
that touches on this is one that Shibley
tell ha me did with Zogby where they
showed that in parts of the Middle East
where you had more media outlets you
tended to get more radical media content
because there was an outbidding effect
and al-jazeera would have to be more
radical to compete with the local
radical TV station third one is
political knowledge so freer media is
going to do any good you would think
that one of the mechanisms would be that
the consumers of the media would know
more and but seventy percent of the
people who voted for Bush knew that
there were in fact weapons of mass
destruction found in Iraq's and we know
that free media doesn't necessarily
produce great political knowledge and so
I'm wondering whether anybody has
actually studied political knowledge as
a function of press freedom a fourth one
is does is the effect of freer media
that there's more consensus about either
political facts or political opinions
free debate people agree on what the
right answer is the truth rises to the
top as John Stuart Mill said or does
free or media tent or to polarize
opinion something that I would think
that you can just like crunch your way
through a data set but I hopefully
somebody has done this but I haven't
seen it fifth one free your media is it
is it more is the consequences of free
questioning is
more segmented or is it more integrated
d when you have free or media do you
just have more and more isolated little
public's talking to themselves as
opposed to somewhat less free media
where there's a national conversation
anyhow I have more questions but I'll
stop there because so why don't we take
two minutes each to respond to Jax any
of Jack's five questions and we can take
the rest up later leave you wonder well
those are unfair questions because I
think you know that the answer is we
don't know the answers to that but there
they are I think the really important
questions the assumption that has been
made in the media development area is
that your poor corte media freedom in
and you get democracy and I think the
there's no evidence to support that the
relationship is clearly much more
complex than that that if you have needy
independence it's going to have to
they're not going to have to be other
components to the society of the
characteristics of society that are
going to bring about the desired outcome
and or in order to bring about the
desired outcome so simply having free
media is not going to produce any of the
outcomes that you've talked about but I
think the questions you've asked is the
right one because the series of
questions are the right ones because
they suggest that we really don't know
very much about what the consequences of
media freedom press freedom are
we have as I indicated my presentation
we have looked at the relationship of
competition and performance and it
appears consistent with so that I think
the presumption of your question is that
when you have extraordinary the high
levels of competition what you have is
and if that's a company with an
inadequate supply of funding funding
opportunities and adequately developed
economy that what you end up getting is
a corrupt media system as opposed to a
system that's really actually in service
of society so we have some data on that
Pittman Norris has been looking at some
of the knowledge questions and I don't
think they're particularly encouraging
if the difficulty is is that you need
comparable measures to take that example
you need comparable measures of
knowledge across a large number of
countries in order to be able to to do
the analysis so you know I think if we
look at at our own situation as we've
had the change in this immediate
environment the proliferation of simple
if you simply take in the broadcast
arena proliferation of broadcast outlets
we've had radically different political
outcome I mean we've had we have
clit ization of the television arena
which didn't exist 10 years ago I don't
think it's produced higher level
knowledge you use the Iraq war example I
don't think it's an increased the tenor
of the political discourse I don't think
it's produced any integration of society
so that would simply be one case which
would suggest that a higher level of
freedom doesn't necessarily produce the
desired outcome that you're speaking of
yeah I definitely would agree with Leon
the comments about the u.s. we don't
really look at any of these issues in
depth this is the kind of thing that I I
wish academics would do and use our data
to look at some of these other issues
but I'll just make a few comments based
on sort of you know what I've seen over
the years I mean definitely I think
increased commercialization and
competition can lead to more
sensationalism more you know jockeying
for four stories and market share and
less professionalism less responsibility
and less quality in some ways so I
definitely don't think there's
necessarily a correlation with any of
with any of these things what we have
looked at at freedom has a little bit
more is the relationship between press
freedom and democracy because we do have
these two global indices and there does
seem to be a knot on the we haven't
really looked at the positive side but
on the negative side there does seem to
be a correlation where press freedom is
seen as a lead indicator of broader
declines in democracy and in many in a
number of countries we've seen declines
in our press freedom index then followed
by declines in the freedom in the world
index and show our broader showing
broader political declines and declines
in civil liberties more broadly so so
that is something that we have we have
seen sort of on the negative scale that
when press freedom is taken away it can
lead to to brought to broader declines
and political freedom and that's that's
on the negative side as I say what we'd
love to have more funding to do a
broader study or to have someone else to
a broader study which would really look
at you know let's say is press freedom a
lead or lag indicator of a political
decline in a positive direction so do
you need a broad political change or
abroad opening in order to lead to a
broad change and press freedom or could
changes in press freedom preclude
broad political opening but definitely
on the decline side it seems that in a
number of different countries over the
last five or five or ten years we have
seen that press freedom is a is a lead
indicator yeah I'll just say briefly
that I think you get into trouble
looking at press indicators in isolation
from the rest of societies and for
example people can complain about the
state of the media in the United States
with justification but it's also in an
educational environment where a lot of
our high school students can't find
Canada on a map much less Japan and so
you create a public market for media and
then the media serves the market it has
that's not generally a press freedom
problem it's a social problem and
Tocqueville you know I had as good a
handle on it as anyone and postman had
second best handle on it so if you look
at civil institutions government how
information circulates what the role of
entertainment is in society whether
there is an Agora a sense of civic
involvement and engagement in a
community where information serves that
purpose then that can be the platform
that makes quality media possible and
without it I think all the freedom in
the world can still get you into the
same cesspool of trivia come back to the
first year question Shack we do have one
measure which speaks to the issue of
media freedom and media quality and that
is in the I Rex index they have five
indices five sub dimensions and one of
them is specifically a performance
dimension that is there they're trying
to look at performance as a part of
sustainability but other parts of
sustainability are not
performance-focused and performance
correlates highly with the other parts
of the index which speaks to the
question of what's the relationship of
freedom and economic viability to
performance there at least within the I
Rex index msi they're correlated my
recollection is pretty highly correlated
point 8 something like that so that
speaks to the first of your questions at
least please thank you my name is Israel
marques I'm a doctoral candidate and
political science department here at
Columbia um and I have a question I
think it's mainly for Lee but but maybe
/ karen as well one of the things that
struck me and in your presentation was
your discussion of how business the the
business environment that journalists
find themselves in may have an effect on
press read freedom and one of the things
that struck me the most about it is I
was doing some work in Russia this
summer and I was told there specifically
that especially in the regions you have
these very interesting dynamics we're in
some regions you know the governor may
simply buy a newspaper you know
something akin to what fujimori did in
peru but what's particularly more
pernicious is the sort of the smarter
governors and other regions would
actually channel advertising funds from
firms that they had access to or
state-owned firms to specific media
outlets in order to sort of you know
having an earth sats control of what
their publishing and so one thing I
wanted to ask you Lee is it seems to me
like one potential way to get around
this in constructing indices is perhaps
to actually make use of these individual
level surveys that you were discussing
earlier and so one thing I wanted to ask
you is whether you think such a thing is
possible but also just because it seems
like we don't and this sort of gets too
I think somewhat to Jack's point as well
because we don't really understand the
dynamics of what individuals really
think about their media and how that
correlates to sort of broader press
freedoms whether you think such a
measure would would even be useful well
I mean I do I think that public opinion
component would be a new dimension in a
valuable dimension to what we know about
media systems in the country so I mean I
think the evidence so far is that that's
something that can and should be added
in the future when one's trying to
understand a country and it's being a
system so to take the outlying cases
that you would have situation where you
had a Vietnam which is a deviant case
Lithuania is the deviant case these are
places where the public is at odds with
the professional evaluate errs and I
think that must tell you something about
that media system either the media
haven't adequately communicated their
independence in one case or they mislead
the public about what their capabilities
are where the government is lit misled
are in the other and those are I think
informative deviant cases so you would
gain something by having that part of
the analytic structure part of the part
of the index the first part of your
question where I thought you were going
was a little different and that is to
really raise the question a question of
what it is we mean by media freedom or
media independence and historically it
meant independence from government and
the indicators were focused on
government constraints I think what
we're coming to understand is that the
government is only part of what
constrains the media environment and
maybe more important is the economic
environment if you have immediate media
that are competing in an economic
environment where they cannot acquire
the resources to function in what we
would call professional fashion there
aren't very many options for them so
they're going to rely on hidden
subsidies government subsidies political
subsidies the journalists are going to
take bribes there's no alternative to
that so if you really want to understand
the viability of the media environment
you also have to understand the vitality
the capability the sustainability of the
economic environment for the media and
that I don't think has been really
adequately addressed in the indices
historically the focus has been on on
the law on
the relationship of government with the
press as opposed to what I I think we
really want to understand about
independence and there's also quite a
lot of work particularly by Europeans
which is arguing that you have to have
alternatives to a commercial media
environment media system so most
Europeans would argue that to take
Germany as an example with a fairly
complex public service media system that
that's a counterbalance to the
commercial forces which would mean that
the existence of that would make the
German media system a more independent
and a free media system than you have in
the United States where we have almost
no alternative to a commercial operation
yep i agree with lee that traditionally
the focus has been more looking at
government controls and repression but i
definitely think that at the moment the
Freedom House index does look at some of
these other issues when we expanded and
deepened our methodology in 2002 which I
was involved with shortly after coming
on at Freedom House we did try and add
in some of these economic issues and at
the moment we do as I said the
categories are weighted somewhat equally
political a little bit more and one of
the main critiques I get of the indexes
that's the economic issues are not
weighted more heavily but we do actually
cover them we do have questions on the
economic side I'm looking at the impact
of advertising and subsidies and these
could be both you know by the government
directing this or private companies or
interests or individuals and we also
questions on bribery and corruption and
how that's
content and we also have issue looking
at issues of ownership of concentration
of ownership of transparency of
ownership and of media sustainability so
we do we do cover some of these issues
although as I said some people argue
that we should maybe wait them a little
bit more heavily but but they do they do
play into the end and into the index as
it is now in the methodology so if you
look on our website and look at all the
questions you'll see a range of other
things we do cover one last quick
question ur coming yeah my name is dr.
Palmer and I'm president and see them I
verte international inc I'm glad you
just poured put you noted the scenario
of issues because I have no the specific
issue primarily because I'm in the
business I understand how it runs and
I'm going to move to Egypt because in my
mind the information from Egypt was very
skewed was all about freedom and so the
news runs a story and everything is
freedom but just recently it's been
noted that one of the CNN female
reporters was gang-raped and if she was
gang-raped and assault that had meant
that she was in the area where the
so-called democratic group was because
she never would have thought of going
into the other area this was not noted
at all the information on women
basically was not noted every once in a
while there would be a camera that's
zeroed in on one woman man can you
phrase it as a question yes well how do
you define this when basically the media
becomes thematic and they're not really
the real issues are not presented that
there's there are themes the base half
of the Egyptian population is illiterate
they never got near the Internet yeah so
this proclaimed as a free revolution was
really not so how do you examine so this
gets I think some hands point about
possible hidden constituencies that
might be out of the purview of media
with anyone want to discuss that
okay thank you well I actually think
that we're in a period we're almost
everything we think we know about the
media is open to challenge you know all
of our theorizing about media
institutions is probably outdated all of
our understanding about journalistic
routines is probably outdated I think
almost all of our literature is if not
it's certainly open to challenge and I
don't have any answer to that but it
seems to me that honestly we have to say
that this is such an incredibly dramatic
change in the media landscape that
almost everything we talked about needs
to be reassessed reconsidered and
rethought and I think your question kind
of suggests that Karen inning yeah just
to jump in I mean it is a is a time of
huge change and I think one of the
challenges for us and for the other
groups that produce the indicators is is
how to change and evolve and update the
indicators to take into account these
changes but also to to keep them enough
the same so that we do have comparable
data sets and this is I think the most
an issue for freedom has because we have
the longest data set but it's an issue
increasingly for other groups as well we
have tried over the last few years to to
update our list of bulleted guidelines
for for our methodology questions both
to look at the impact of the internet
and new media as well as the the
changing landscape of journalism and how
news production and consumption is
taking place so looking at bloggers
citizen journalists as opposed to
professional journalists and all the
different ways in which people are
getting their information now you know
by a mobile phone by the internet so
we're really trying to to sort of tweak
the the methodology but but keep it
within the same framework now I don't
know how much longer we can you can do
this for and we are thinking about
trying to you know have a broader more
in-depth discussion about our method
going forward so we'll we'll see how it
goes but I think that is a challenge for
all of us and all of these indicator
projects I'm particularly I think in the
media sphere more than let's say I with
the democracies fear more generally just
because it is such a changing
environment and very very fast I spent a
lot of time writing about the
relationship between legacy media and
digital media and they're both important
they're both really important I I spend
a lot of time kind of defending the need
to hold on to legacy media and news
institutions that have reporters and
editors and fact-checkers and a way of
defining the world but one of the other
attributes of legacy media is that they
they work within the framework of a
master narrative and for and when I was
a reporter in El Salvador I thought okay
el salvador owns the story because it's
on the front page of the New York Times
every day and then all of a sudden it
wasn't and Poland was and I realized at
that point that stories have their
shapes their ways of being told by
institutions the ways of playing out in
the world and that is the world
according to the New York Times and we
probably like it enough to read the
paper now I just experienced Egypt
through Twitter and I had a very
fragmented representation that had many
many more points of view many of them
local straight from Tahrir Square and
elsewhere in the Middle East but on the
other hand I wasn't sure what was true I
wouldn't know what was confirmed nothing
was edited
and I had both halves of legacy and
digital media at the same time but I
don't feel like it's a finished product
I feel that in 10 years we're all going
to be looking at something totally
different looking forward to that so
thank you all for a participating thing
to our panels for a wonderful discussion